i want to introduce you to somebody not
him i want a german
no i want to introduce you well to
somebody
this channel is called indigo party
monsters relationship
footage catchy name it's wordy
is it an acronym for something can we go
back i want to see what the
the acronym is so is it
um ref imperf
okay okay not very good you'll work on
that
so uh first off all the credit for this
goes to jj stoner d live.tv slash jj
stone
trying to do my show man he sent this to
me and it's been beautiful now
we had um
somebody one of our favorite people that
we used to follow and track their
progress or demise whichever way you
look at it dayton hypernova
has not made videos in the long run
he's not dead has not ripped his career
his career yes has not made videos now i
don't say this lightly but i think we
have a contender
hey he doesn't say anything lightly
you're heavy i know
i know mike
15 they're breaking up threads on the
internet today
don't say it did you see it so i believe
that this person
or these people because it's two people
are the contenders
for the crown and i'm going to leave it
up to you to decide
okay here you go it makes me a reaction
i can't be around this
[ __ ] anymore what the [ __ ] is this
sorry this is before we got arrested
separately
my car went underwater okay
so this has been a fun day for you
they're a gay couple we heard you
shouldn't talk about
them in public turn the camera off
i'm gonna
zodiac sign like jimin
leave me alone i'm just trying to have
my bike here and by the way this i i
love
the obviously southern setting of this
too yes
is that that's like that guy has a
variation of jj stoner's catchphrase i'm
just trying to rob my bike man
leave me alone man well get out of the
[ __ ] round thank you
ditch back loser the [ __ ] out of the
[ __ ] road
get up behind me too all because he
didn't answer what his uh zodiac sign
was
they don't i don't want him calling him
get the [ __ ] out of the wrong you dumb
now there's a reason why i'm calling the
police these guys like to partake in
methamphetamine i was
gonna say that there's any time somebody
goes
hey man i don't want them calling the
cops i could tell you nine times out of
ten
they probably have drugs on them one of
the reasons why
back when when you've seen me be very
reasonable in any situation nine times
out of ten it's because i had drugs on
me and i'm like look that's not [ __ ]
that's fine we'll kick his ass later
well i gotta drop the [ __ ] off there's
kids go
there's kids hey what's your straw
design oh my god
asking children little kids it's always
good you know in 2020 i would say this
it's always great to
um you know talk to kids from a car
it's always very smart hey come over
here get in
come talk to me i want to ask you
questions about your astrology
now somebody earlier said this is
lindsey graham's origin story
i answered lindsey graham's nephew's out
here representing there's a sidewalk
thank you
thank you get the [ __ ] out of the road
don't mind him no don't [ __ ] mind
your [ __ ] selfie piece
now this is what this gentleman looks
like wow okay so these two were
awesome very cool [ __ ] dude make
we both went pee at the same time we're
in the middle of nowhere
nowhere middle of nowhere get in the car
come on good acting like a psycho please
you're an idiot get back in my car and
i'm just gonna take you home cause
you're [ __ ] being stupid
we're going to jodi's house right now go
with me
i'm not going with you i hate you if you
missed a scream oh will you hit me
i went peeing or mad about it no one saw
me
i almost peed on my legs shut the [ __ ]
up about it get in my car
let's go you're sucking stupid i
i'm like i'm trying to find a way to say
this in a way that
doesn't come off you know like i'm
generalizing or saying something
i hate
am i the only one that just just their
whole
thing what you're acting
really stupid as [ __ ] hey let's be you
you're both acting stupid oh this gets
this is nothing
i've talked on service get in my car if
you don't have phone service
i'm not leaving you here at all
i'm just sick and tired i just want us
to be respectable meth and cokey with
the
guys could've just said guys get in my
car
we're trying to find our house what the
[ __ ] i just went pee that's all i did
why are you acting like that why are you
acting so
[ __ ] stupid
i am now lowering the dayton hypernova
flag
and i am raising their flag i said flag
my car
is on are you done yet acting like an
idiot this is this is how i wouldn't
wouldn't you
follow him in the car this is how the
well you'll see this is how the fighter
and the kid met
do you want origin stories of fighter in
the kids
you know you're acting so [ __ ] stupid
so
stupid okay you're calling someone to
give you a cab
for what in the middle of the field
it's you have no reason for this [ __ ]
i'm not running out to you you just did
though
[ __ ] it what a [ __ ] one
god you're [ __ ] stupid and difficult
as [ __ ]
you [ __ ] little baby shut the [ __ ] up
yeah because you're running in the
middle of nowhere
and i'm worried about it you're a
[ __ ] idiot
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you we
already know something's wrong with you
it's on your [ __ ] head no one can
hear us
just come on don't make me when
my dazzle is [ __ ] to turn around
circles by the way are you
dying these are both somebody's son yeah
yeah did you run and walk him down
he finally gets in his car
but he keeps recording it's important
that he keeps reporting
the narcissist come on
just come on please don't do this to me
no
that's the medical alert of my family
i'm getting help i pressed the medical
alert so an ambulance is just gonna come
and pick me up listen i am wasting
precious uh infrastructure and resources
because i'm fighting with my
boyfriend over meth so i hit the medic
alert
uh yeah okay fine some woman may not get
a rat kit or some old lady might just
die
on her floor in her bathtub if i hit the
medic alert button i hate these people
i hate these two oh you're gonna hate it
more if i
don't go to her house oh my god i just
realized this is a 38 minute video
we don't have to play the whole thing
but we're going to but i'm like wow wait
did you see the channel
like this this is why do you think it's
peaceable to stand out there just like
this
yeah it is like where are we at nowhere
i don't want no one to look at me pee
wow i didn't want to pee in my car i
don't want to
look at me peace so i drove five miles
out of the way into the middle of the
wilderness
how about fighting a 7-eleven you
[ __ ] weirdo yeah and just buying like
a candy bar
wow how many times have you done that in
your life you know what i'll buy a cup
of coffee
ring it up here's here's two i'm gonna
go pee and i'll go
get something please and then stop
acting like that
and then of course because there's not
enough attention stop it
he passes out on please by the way he's
fine
he's fine why did you do that
i can't be with you you can't be with
yourself look what you did
go away i have to go away when you just
act like like that
just get in the car everything's gonna
be fine i'm not getting in anywhere with
you
why why do i why am i
why do i get in trouble when i when i
designate this kind of [ __ ] as a mental
illness
because you're a bigot but it's clear
i mean again statistically right
that's a problem in that in in those
circles yes i'm glad you didn't say jerk
afterwards
now he gets in the car and uh there's a
quick little flash pan finally when he
gets in the car to them
getting pulled over
it might be
am i being detained i don't need any
paperwork sure and it takes a lot for me
to say this but i feel so bad for this
cop
check us out
look how rational they handle this the
gas station
we pull out of the gas station you get
behind us then you pull up beside us
because he's got many depressive
whatever
and you freaking out and now i'm freaked
out you basically pull this over for no
reason why'd you pull this over you can
hush your [ __ ] mouth
okay that's awesome i'm very happy
with this cop right now he knows you
[ __ ] mouth somebody goes
am i being detained because i have my
own handcuffs oh my [ __ ] god this cop
rules you could hush your [ __ ] mouth
and by the way i i love that this cop
sat there and let him finish oh yeah he
was babbling babbling babbling babbling
and was like you need to shut the [ __ ]
up
aj what city is this in because he's got
many depressive whatever and you freak
him out and now i'm freaked out it seems
like based on the accent north carolina
or virginia
it has to be that area mississippi
they pull that seven for that reason
why'd you pull this out you can hush
your [ __ ] mouth oh really yeah we're
live right now
i don't care i don't either
i'm not sure about the shitty but the
city the shitty what makes sense the
shitty city
uh but uh pretty sure it's arkansas okay
pull this over for no [ __ ] reason now
they get really big
and then now he's gonna take me to jail
for disorderly conduct but i'm in a car
and he can't do [ __ ] about it
does he think that a car is like a
shield from the police
cop can't get in this domicile did they
see that uh
video of that ups driver yeah i pulled
over for no
[ __ ] reason
how do people not i see we've watched a
million videos like this
look i'm no fan of police officers i
think
we've made that perfectly clear over the
years that i don't i have any affinity
for law enforcement
but there's a time like there's a time
when you just kind of go let's get
through this as pain
yep painlessly as possible i want to get
home you want to argue
did i did i do something back there or
uh oh okay well yeah
there's my id and uh sure just make sure
it checks out
you just be polite and wait and that's
it and then when they leave you go
[ __ ] it peace [ __ ] pig [ __ ] and he
pulled us over from over he didn't get
my [ __ ] name
you got to tell me i committed a crime
because you ain't getting my
sovereign citizen i called that hhcc
news
okay it's okay it's okay [ __ ]
pulled over
[Music]
he gets out of the car and he asked the
cop
i want you to watch this again it's
really important it's okay
yeah okay will you say what your
strategy
is without knowing what my wife what
what my what
uh listen uh i'm gonna need you to uh
turn around put your hands on the car
i don't know what a stroller is okay
wait my finger okay i'll turn it off
the other guy gets out of the car even
though the cop told them don't get out
of the car
because there's one cop and obviously
you're a cop you want two people you
know it's harder to manage
you get back in the car you get back in
the car
no i didn't know anything the police
were at the gas station it's okay
it's okay it's okay if you don't you're
gonna go to jail don't do it
don't don't do it dude
somebody says i can't believe these two
weren't arrested wait for it no no no
no no no no no no no don't do it don't
do it don't do it don't
don't do it please don't leave i promise
you you didn't mean to he didn't mean to
please i've heard you know
well this this was on the episode of
live dp
that's very funny
[Music]
get back over there he's trying to get
home to get his peel i bet
here get over there get back over there
sorry i'm bopping i didn't do anything
get home you didn't do
he went from i don't care if he arrests
me i don't give a [ __ ]
to i'm sorry i apologize sir i feel like
you don't
uh uh really think these things through
before you run your mouth
because like roy said one minute ago i
was like i don't even give [ __ ]
go ahead and read i don't care if i go
to jeddah oh my god i'm freaking out
sorry i'm sorry please don't tell me
sorry i didn't
i don't have your number
how does he not have his number i mean
nowadays who [ __ ]
memorizes numbers no but when you go to
your phone right and they let you
sometimes they don't let you have it oh
god i don't remember it either
it's okay i love you
okay you will
[Music]
i love him i love you
they were fine i love you i love you i'm
sorry
i love you i wish there was somebody to
tell if you loved it i'm gonna close
this door okay
it's okay
now the cop comes back the cop comes
back no i'm sorry i don't know
i had to just i just i gave it to him oh
he's already got it
yeah will you say your astrology sign
for me is that okay
what is
what is wrong with this person